[Music]
president zielinski has traveled to
America
leaving Ukraine for the first time since
the War Began
with war death's back home estimated to
be in the tens of thousands
he's Shoring up support and after more
weapons
the economists Russia and Eastern Europe
editor arcade ostrovsky secured
interviews with president zielinski
president
General zalushny
and Commander searsky three of Ukraine's
most senior officials
together with our defense editor
Shashank Joshi he discusses what their
Revelations tell us about the next
stages of the war the message is very
clear the war is not going to stop until
Ukraine gets to the borders of 1991
freezing the lines now uh would be very
dangerous
[Music]
on the East it's like in World War II
during very difficult battles it's
really warm with fire with shelters with
rockets with everything artillery so
with everything and in Kiev you see
not so dangerous but they begin to use
Rockets since Russia started this uh
barrage basically half 50 percent of
power generation of Ukraine uh has been
lost there is darkness in every sense of
the word you know this is not a movie
This is the real life and we should not
underestimate the amount of strain
psychological strain people are under
these blackouts are due to attacks on
power grids including the iranian-made
drones
they're not very good but they don't
have to be good they only have to be
good enough to hit the right things
insufficient numbers and Russia is now
in potentially indigenizing the
production of those systems that's going
to be a big problem for Ukraine however
the really big problem would be if Iran
makes a decision to supply short-range
and medium-range ballistic missiles
things like the zulphicar system if it
were to do that it would essentially
allow Russia to keep up this rate of
Relentless attack on Ukraine cities and
infrastructure
but it is illusionary is certain that
Russians are already rebuilding uh
somewhere behind the Euros both in
munition and Manpower and they are
preparing for a fresh offensive and he
said this could come uh possibly as soon
as end of January uh possibly in March
if they're lucky and most likely uh in
February he was talking about some 200
Russian 200 000 Russian troops and his
fearing attack or counter offensive in
uh several directions in the South uh in
the East he said the Russians could go
again and threaten Adesa Nick alive and
as well as in the direction of Belarus
and Cave Vladimir Putin visited Belarus
on December 19th and there's been
heightened military activity there there
is a sense that an attack could come
from the north now what we have been
told is that Belarus has probably given
away too much of its supplies ammunition
and other material to the Russians to
conduct an attack itself or to take part
in one and I am skeptical that we would
see a serious attempt from the north and
if you're looking at this from the
perspective of Vladimir Putin who who
says what do I want to take most of all
the bit that he doesn't have is the rest
of Donetsk Province uh and taking that
would allow him to say he has liberated
or captured the entirety of donbass and
if you were a Ukrainian Commander
assessing your options the really
ambitious place for a Ukrainian
offensive would be melatopo because they
would be able to get their High Mars
rocket launchers within range of Russian
supply lines all the way from Russian
territory to Crimea but of course we
have to remember for the ukrainians
isn't just territory more than 95 or 96
percent of people want to do occupied
all their territory after after
a Russian did it I think the most big
mistake or the big mistake was on on
2014 but the biggest mistake
the tragic
dredgedy was on 24th of February because
that is the point when nobody wants to
come back to any compromises in no
conversations did I get a sense that
they're unrealistic and they're about
you know they're gang her and they want
to go and March into Crimea
um I think zielinski uh is now talking
about we can completely see sort of the
the return of Crimea by non-military
means I think what he means by that is
if Putin is defeated if there is a
change of regime the status Crimea will
be completely renegotiated
with months possibly years of grueling
conflict ahead president zielinski
continues to stand not just against
Putin but for what he believes is life's
most fundamental principle
Save Your Love
save your love for your life is your
neighbors your relatives your your
parents your children your your nation
that is what we love after 10 months of
the war you have love and not hate
I have love and I have hate I told you
to whom I have
[Music]
to read more of our coverage on the war
in Ukraine and the events in Russia
please click on the link
and thank you for watching don't forget
to subscribe